bientôt la fin des vacances c'est pour
certains le retour des petits rituels
comme faire ses courses au marché lui
est l'un des plus anciens de la région
le marché Velpeau à Tours attire deux
fois par semaine des centaines de
clients venus acheter fruits et légumes
mais aussi vêtements un moyen également
de préserver la vie de quartier à
l'heure d'Internet et des drives le
reportage d'Aurélie Renaud
Richard etapiculteur a asé sur Cher il
vient sur le marché Velpeau depuis 40
ans comme le faisait son père sa
clientèle vient de tour et des environs
de 30 km
30 km
ils viennent spécialement à Velpeau pour
aller choisir et puis voilà leur
commerçants et leurs producteurs qui
qu'ils adorent primeur boucherie
charcuterie poissonnerie traiteur à côté
de l'alimentaire le textile des stands
plus compliquées moins nombreux Aziz
destocks de grandes marques la
concurrence d'Internet se fait sentir
chez lui depuis 10-15 ans saxo
changer la jeunesse ne vient plus sur le
marché Velpeau a tout de même ses
habitués côté clientèle beaucoup
viennent ici chaque dimanche on n'est
pas très loin mais il y a beaucoup de
diversités aussi c'est assez agréable il
y a beaucoup de choses donc c'est une
bonne ambiance donc c'est c'est très
bien c'est quoi que tu aimes bien au
marché
les marchands de fruits et légumes parce
qu'ils donnent des bonbons c'est mon
marché préféré du dimanche j'habite à
400 mètres et après on finit dans un
petit bistrot à prendre l'apéritif et on
rentre chez soi il est 14h
plusieurs commerçants n'hésitent pas à
faire plus d'une heure de route pour
être présent pierre et maraîcher bio
dans la Sarthe Velpeau et pour lui un
marché incontournable si je veux de la
clientèle suffisamment de clientèle et
il faut de la il faut de la ville moi je
suis en pleine campagne et le bio en
campagne en Sarthe
c'est pas encore très bien installé dans
les mentalités
il y a une quinzaine d'années le marché
Velpeau accueillait 140 commerçants
certains ont pris leur retraite ils sont
aujourd'hui un peu plus d'une centaine